all right everybody let's get started
today the paper four days I'm is aunt
Aurora paper which is all about how to
get a high-performance reliable database
going as a piece of cloud infrastructure
and itself built out of infrastructure
that Amazon itself makes available so
the reason why we're reading this paper
is that first of all it's a very
successful recent cloud service from
Amazon a lot of their customers use it
it shows sort of in its own way an
example of a very big payoff from clever
design table one which sort of
summarizes the performance shows that
relative to some other system which is
not very well explained the paper claims
to get a thirty five times speed up in
transaction throughput which is
extremely impressive this paper also
kind of explores the limits of how well
you can do for performance and fault
tolerance using general-purpose storage
because one of the themes of the papers
they basically abandoned general-purpose
storage they switch from a design in
which they were using their Amazon's own
general-purpose storage infrastructure
decided it was not good enough and
basically built totally
application-specific storage
furthermore the paper has a lot of
little tidbits about what turned out to
be important in this and the kind of
cloud infrastructure world so before
talking about aurora i want to spend a
bit of time kind of going over the back
history or what my impression is about
the story that led up to the design of
aurora because it's you know the sort of
m f-- way that amazon has in mind that
you ought to build that their cloud
customers ought to build databases on
amazon's infrastructure so in the
beginning amazon had basically their
very first offering cloud offering to
support people who wanted to build
websites but using Amazon's hardware and
in Amazon's machine room their first
offering was something called ec2
for elastic cloud apparently too and the
idea here is that Amazon had big machine
rooms full of servers and they ran
virtual machine monitors on their
servers and they'd rent out virtual
machines to their customers and their
customers would then you know rent a
bunch of virtual machines and run web
servers and databases and whatever ever
all else they needed to run inside these
ec2 instances so the picture of one
physical server looked like this Amazon
we control the virtual machine monitor
on this hardware server and then there'd
be a bunch of guests a bunch of ec2
instances each one rented out to a
different cloud customer each of these
would just run a standard operating
system like Linux and then you know a
web server or maybe a database server
and these were relatively cheap
relatively easy to set up and as a very
successful service so one little detail
that's extremely important for us is
that initially the way you get storage
the way you've got storage if you rented
an ec2 instance was that every one of
their servers had a disk attached a
physical disk attached and each one of
these instances that they rented to
their customers will get us you know a
slice of the disk so they said locally
attached storage and you got a bit of
locally attached storage which itself
just look like a hard drive an emulated
hard drive to the virtual machine guests
ec2 is like perfect for web servers for
stateless web servers you know your
customers with their web browsers would
connect to a bunch of rented ec2
instances that ran a web server and if
you added all of a sudden more customers
you could just instantly rent more ec2
instances from
Amazon and fire up web servers on them
and sort of an easy way to scale up your
ability to handle web load so it was
good for web servers
but the other main thing that people ran
in ec2 instance this was databases
because usually a website is constructed
of a set of stateless web servers that
anytime they need to get out permanent
data go talk to a back-end database so
what you would get is is maybe a bunch
of client browsers in the outside world
outside of Amazon's web infrastructure
and then a number of ec2 web server
instances as many as you need it to run
the sort of logic of the website this
this is now inside Amazon and then also
some also typically one ec2 instance
running a database your web servers
would talk to your database instance and
ask it to read and write records in the
database unfortunately ec2 wasn't
perfect was it nearly as well-suited to
running a database as it was to running
web servers and the most immediate
reason is that the storage or the sort
of main easy way to get storage for your
ec2 database instance was on the locally
attached disk attached to whatever a
piece of hardware your database instance
was currently running on in fact
hardware crashed then you also lost
access to whatever what is on its hard
drive so if it's a hardware that it was
actually implementing a web server
crashed no problem at all because
there's really keeps no state itself you
just fire up a new web server on a new
ec2 instance if the ec2 instance it's a
hardware running it crashes have become
unavailable you have a serious problem
if the data is stored on the locally
attached disk so initially at least
there wasn't sort of a lot of help for
doing this one thing that did work out
well is that Amazon did provide this
sort of large scheme for storing large
chunks of data called s3 and you could
take snapshots you could take Prius
periodic snapshots if you need a basis
state and stored in s3 and use that for
sort of backup disaster recovery but you
know that style of periodic snapshots
means you're gonna lose updates that
happen
between the periodic backups all right
so the next thing that came along that's
that's relevant to the sort of Aurora
database story is that in order to
provide their customers with disks for
their ec2 instances that didn't go away
if there was a failure that is more sort
of fault tolerant long-term storage was
guaranteed to be there Amazon introduced
the service called EBS and this stands
for elastic block store
so with EBS is is a service that looks
to an ec2 instances it looks to one of
these instances one of these guest
virtual machines just as if it were a
hard drive an ordinary way you could
format it as a hard drive but a file
system like ext3 or whatever Linux file
system you like on this on this thing
that looks to be guest just like a hard
drive but the way it's actually
implemented is as a replicated pair of
storage servers so this is the local
this is one of local storage with Mike
if when EBS came out then you could you
could rent an e BS volume which this
thing that looks just like an ordinary
hard drive but it's actually implemented
as a pair so these are EBS servers a
pair of EBS servers each with an
attached hard drive so if your software
here maybe you're running a database now
and your databases mount's one of these
EBS volumes as its storage when the
database server doesn't write what that
actually means is that the right to send
out over the network and using chain
replication which we talked about last
week you're right is you know first
written to the EBS server one on the
first CBS server that's backing your
volume and then the second one and
finally you get the reply and similarly
when you do a read I guess some chain
replication you'll be the last of the
chain so now database is running on ec2
instances had available a storage system
that actually would survive the crash of
or the you know death of the hardware
that they were running on if this
physical server died you could just get
another ec2 instance fire up your
database and have it attached to the
same old EBS volume that the sort of
previous version of your database was
attached to and it would see all the old
data just as it had been left off by the
previous database just like you moved a
hard drive from one machine to another
so EBS was like really a good deal for
people who need it to keep permanent
state like people running databases one
thing to that is sort of important for
us about EBS is that it's really it's
not a system for sharing at any one time
only one ec2 instance only one virtual
machine can mount a given EBS volume so
the EBS volumes are implemented on a
huge fleet of you know hundreds or
whatever storage servers with disks at
Amazon and they're all you know
everybody's EBS volumes are stored on
this big pool of servers but each one of
each PPS volume can only be used by only
one ec2 instance only one customer all
right still EBS was a big step up but it
had still has some problems so there's
still some things that are not quite as
perfect as it could be one is that if
you run a database on EBS it ends up
sending large volumes of data across the
network and this is uh we're now
starting to sort of sneak up on figure
two in the the paper where they start
complaining about how many just how many
writes it takes if you run a database on
top of a network storage system so
there's the database on EBS ended up
generating a lot of network traffic and
one of the kind of things in the paper
that the paper implies is that they're
as much network limited as they are CPU
or storage limited that is they pay a
huge amount of attention to reducing the
Aurora paper sends a huge amount of
attention for reducing the network
that the database generates and seems to
be worrying less about how much CPU time
or disk space is being consumed that's a
sort of a hint at what they think is
important the other problem with EBS is
not very fault tolerant it turns out
that for performance reasons they I'm
done would always put both of the EBS
both of the replicas of your EBS volume
in the same data center and so we have a
single server crashed if you know one of
the two EBS servers that you're using
crashed it's okay because you switch to
the other one but there was just no
story at all for what happens if an
entire data center went down and and
apparently a lot of customers really
wanted a story that would allow their
data to survive an outage of an entire
data center maybe it lost his network
connection it was a fire in the building
or a power failure to the whole building
or something people really wanted to
have at least the option if they're
willing to pay more of having their data
stored in a way they hid they could
still get at it I'm even if one data
center goes down and the way that Amazon
described this there is that both an
instance and its EBS to EBS replicas are
in the same ability veil ability zone
and an Amazon jargon an availability
zone is a particular data center and the
way they structure their data centers is
that there's usually multiple
independent data centers in more or less
the same city or relatively close to
each other and all the multiple
availability zones maybe two or three
that are near by each other are all
connected by redundant high speed
networks so there's always payers or
triples of nearby availability
availability centers and we'll see the
buy that's important in a little bit but
at least for EBS in order to keep the
sort of costs of using chain replication
down they required the two replicas to
be in the same availability zone
all right um before I dive into more
into how Aurora actually works it turns
out that the details of the design in
order to understand them we first have
to know a fair amount about the sort of
design of typical databases because what
they taken is sort of the main machinery
of a database my sequel as it happens
and split it up in an interesting way so
we need to know sort of what it but it
is a database does so we can understand
how they split it up so this is really a
kind of database tutorial really
focusing on what it takes to implement
transactions crashed recoverable
transactions so what I really care about
is transactions and crash recovery and
there's a lot else going on in databases
but this is really the part that matters
for this paper so first what's a
transaction you know transaction is just
a way of wrapping multiple operations on
maybe different pieces of data and
declare in that that that's entire
sequence of operations should appear a
Tomic to anyone else who's reading or
writing the data so you might see
transposing we're running a bank and we
want to do transfers between different
accounts maybe you would say well we
would see code or you know see a
transaction looks like this is you have
to clear the beginning of the sequence
of instructions that you want to be
atomic in the in transaction maybe we're
going to transfer money from account Y
to account X so we might see where I'll
just pretend X is a bank balance Jordan
the database you might see the
transaction looks like oh can I add $10
to X's account and
deduct the same ten dollars from my
account and that's the end of the
transaction
I want the database to just do them both
without allowing anybody else to sneak
in and see the state between these two
statements and also with respect to
crashes if there's a crash at this point
somewhere in here we're going to make
sure that after the crash and recovery
that either the entire transactions
worth the modifications are visible or
none of them are so that's the effect we
want from transactions there's
additionally people expect database
users expect that the database will tell
them tell the client that submitted the
transaction whether the transaction
really finished and committed or not and
if a transaction is committed we expect
clients expect that the transaction will
be permanent will be durable still there
even if the database should crash and
reboot um one thing it's a bit important
is that the usual way these are
implemented is that the transaction
locks each piece of data before it uses
it so you can view the they're being
locks x and y for the duration of the
transaction and these are only released
after the transaction finally commits
that is known to be permanent this is
important if you for some of the things
that you have to if you some of the
details in the paper really only makes
sense if you realize that the database
is actually locking out other access to
the data during the life of a
transaction so how this actually
implemented it turns out the database
consists of at least for the simple
database model where the databases are
typically written to run on a single
server with you know some storage
directly attached and a game that the
Aurora paper is playing is sort of
moving that software only modestly
revised in order to run on a much more
complex network system but the starting
point is we just assume we have a
database with a attached to a disk the
on disk structure that stores these
records is some kind of indexing
structure like a b-tree maybe so
there's a sort of pages with the paper
calls data pages that holds us you know
real data of the of the database you
know maybe this is excess balances and
this is wise balance these data pages
typically hold lots and lots of records
whereas X and y are typically just a
couple bites on some page in the
database so on the disk there's the
actual data plus on the disk there's
also a right ahead log or wal and the
right ahead logs are a critical part of
why the system is gonna be fault
tolerant inside the database server
there's the database software the
database typically has a cache of pages
that it's read from the disk that it's
recently used when you execute a
transaction what that actually executes
these statements what that really means
is you know what x equals x plus 10
turns into the runtime is that the
database reads the current page holding
X from the disk and adds 10 to it but so
far until the transaction commits it
only makes the modifications in the
local cache not on the disk because we
don't want to expose we don't want to
write on the disk yet and the part
possibly expose a partial transaction so
while then when the database but before
because the database wants to sort of
pre to clear the complete transaction so
it's available to the software after a
crash and during recovery before the
database is allowed to modify the real
data pages on disk its first required to
add log entries that describe the
transaction so it has to in order before
it can commit the transaction it needs
to put a complete set of log ahead
entries in the right ahead log on disk
I'm describing all the data bases
modification so let's suppose here that
x and y start out as say 500 and y
starts out as 750 and we want to execute
this transaction before committing and
before writing the pages the database is
going to add at least typically 3 log
records 1 this that says well as part of
this transaction I'm modifying X
and it's old value is 500 make more room
here this is the on dis log so each log
entry might say here's the value I'm
modifying here's the old value and we're
adding and here's the new value say five
ten so that's one log record another 4y
may be old value is 750 we're
subtracting 10 so the new value is 740
and then when the database if it
actually manages to get to the end of
the transaction before crashing its
gonna write a commit record saying and
typically these are all tagged with some
sort with a transaction ID so that the
recovery software eventually will know
how this commit record refers to these
log records yes
in a simple database will be enough to
just store the new values and say well
it is a crash we're gonna just reapply
all the new values the reason most
serious databases store the old as well
as a new value is to give them freedom
to even for a long-running traction for
a long-running transaction even before
the transaction is finished it gives the
database the freedom to write the
updated page to disk with the new value
740 let's say from the from an
uncompleted transaction as long as it's
written the log record to disk and then
if there's a crash before the commit the
recovery software always say aha well
this transaction never finished
therefore we have to undo all of its
changes and these values these old
values are the values you need in order
to undo a transaction that's been
partially written to the data pages so
the aurora indeed uses undo redo logging
to be able to undo partially applied
transactions okay so if the database
manages to get as far as getting the
transactions log records on the disk and
the commit record marking is finished
then it is entitled to apply to the
client we said the transactions
committed the database can reply to the
client and the client can be assured
that its transaction will be sort of
visible forever and now one of two
things happens the database server
doesn't crash then eventually so it's
modified in its cache these these X&Y
records to be 510 and 740 eventually the
database will write it's cached updated
blocks to their real places on the disk
over writing you know these be tree
nodes or something and then the database
can reuse this part of the log so
databases tend to be lazy about that
because they like to accumulate you know
maybe there'll be many updates to these
pages in the cache it's nice to
accumulate a lot of updates before being
forced to write the disk if the database
server crashes before writing the day
writing these pages to the disk so they
still have their old values then it's
guaranteed that the recovery software
when you restart that
debase scan the log see these records
for the transaction see that that
transaction was committed and apply the
new values to the to the stored data and
that's called a redo it basically does
all the rights in the transaction so
that's how transactional databases work
in a nutshell and so this is a sort of
very extremely abbreviated version of
how for example the my sequel database
works that an Aurora is based on this
open source software thing called
database called my sequel which does
crash recovery transaction and crash
recovery in much this way ok so the next
step in Amazon's development a better
and better database infrastructure for
its cloud customers is something called
RDS and I'm only talking about RDS
because it turns out that even though
the paper doesn't quite mention it
figure 2 in the paper is basically a
description of RDS so what's going on
and RDS is that it was a first attempt
to get a database that was replicated in
multiple availability zones so that if
an entire data center went down you
could get back your database contents
without missing any rights so that deal
with RDS is that there's one you have
one ec2 instance that's the database
server
you just have one you just want to
running one database it stores its data
pages and log just basically with this
instead of on the local disk its stores
them in EBS so whenever the database
does a log write or page write or
whatever those rights actually go to
these two EBS volumes EBS replicas in
addition so and so this is in one
availability zone in addition for every
write that the database software does
Amazon would transparently without the
database even realizing necessarily this
was happened also send those rights to
a special set up in a second
availability zone in a second machine
room - just going from figure 2 to
apparently a separate computer or ec2
instance or something whose job was just
a mirror writes that the main database
did so this other sort of mirroring
server would then just copy these rights
to a second pair of EBS servers and so
with this set up with this RDS set up
and that's what figure - every time the
database appends to the log or writes to
one of its pages it has to the data has
to be sent to these two replicas has to
be sent on the network connection across
the other availability zone on the other
side of town sent to this mirroring
server which would then send it to it's
two separate EBS replicas and then
finally this reply would come back and
then only then with the right be
finished with a DAT bc AHA my writes
finished I can you know count this log
record it was really being appendage of
the log or whatever
so this RDS arrangement gets you betcha
better fault tolerance because now you
have a complete up-to-date copy of the
database like seeing them all the very
latest writes in a separate availability
zone even if you know fire burns down
this entire data center boom you can
weaken you can run the database in a new
instance and the second availability
zone and lose no data at all yes
um I don't know how to answer that I
mean that is just not what they do and
my guess is that it would be that for
most EVs customers it would be too
painfully slow to forward every right
across two separate data center I'm not
really sure what's going on but I think
the main answers they don't do that and
this is sort of a a little bit of a
workaround for the way EBS works too
kind of tricky BS and actually producing
and sort of using the existing EBS
infrastructure unchanged I stableman
chose this turns out to be extremely
expensive or anyway it's expensive as
you might think
you know we're writing fairly large
volumes of data because you know even
this transaction which seems like it
just modifies two integers like maybe
eight bytes or I don't know what sixteen
who knows only a few bytes of data are
being modified here what that translates
to as far as the database reading and
writing the disk is I actually these log
records are that also quite small so
this these two log records might
themself only be dozens of bytes long so
that's nice but the reads and writes of
the actual data pages are likely to be
much much larger than just a couple of
dozen bytes because each of these pages
is going to be you know eight kilobytes
or 16 kilobytes or some relatively large
number the file system or disk block
size and it means that just to read and
write these two numbers when it comes
time to update the data pages there's a
lot of data being pushed around on to
the disk a locally attached disk now
it's reasonably fast but I guess what
they found is when they start sending
those big 8 kilobyte writes across the
network that that used up too much
network capacity to be supported and so
this arrangement this figure 2
arrangement evidently was too slow yes
so in this in this figure to set up the
you know unknown to the database server
every time it called write erode its EBS
disk a copy of every write went over
across availabilities zones and had to
be written to the was written to the
both of these EBS servers and then
acknowledged and only then did the write
appear to complete to the database so I
really had to wait for all the fall for
copies to be updated and for the data to
be sent on the link across to the other
availability zone and you know as far as
table one it's concerned that first
performance table the reason why the
reason why the slow the mirrored my
sequel line is much much slower than the
Aurora line is basically that it sends
huge amounts of data over these
relatively slow Network links and that
was the problem that was the performance
problem they're really trying to fix so
this is good for fault tolerance because
now we have a second copy and another
availability zone but it was bad news
for performance all right the way Aurora
and the next step after this is Aurora
and to set up there the high level view
is we still have a database server
although now it's running custom
software that Amazon supplies so I can
rent an Aurora server from Amazon but
it's not I'm not running my software on
it I'm renting a server running Amazon's
Aurora database software on it rent an
Aurora database server from them and
it's it's just one instance it sits in
some availability zone and there's two
interesting things about the way it's
set up first of all is that the data you
know it's replacement basically for EBS
involves six replicas now
- in each of three availability zones
for super fault tolerance and so every
time the database complicated we'll talk
but basically when the database writes
or reads when the database writes it's
we're not sure exactly how its managed
but it more or less needs to send a
write one way or another writes have to
get sent to all six of these replicas
the key to making and so this looks like
more replicas gosh you know why isn't it
slower why isn't it slower than this
previous scheme which only had four
replicas and the answer to that is that
what's being the only thing being
written over the network is the log
records so that's really the key to
success is that the data that goes over
these links in the sense of the replicas
it's just the log records log entries
and as you can see you know a log entry
here you know at least and this is a
simple example now it's not quite this
small but it's really not vastly more
than a couple of dozen bytes needed to
store the old value and the new value
for the piece of data we're writing so
the log entries tend to be quite small
whereas when the database you know we
had a database that thought it was
writing a local disk and it was updating
its data pages these tended to be
enormous like doesn't really say in the
paper I don't think that eight kilobytes
or more so this set up here was sending
for each transaction was sending
multiple 8 kilobyte pages across to the
replicas whereas this set up is just
sending these small log entries to more
replicas but the log entries are so very
much smaller than 8k pages that it's a
net performance win okay so that's one
this is like one of their big insights
is just in the log entries of course a
fallout from this is that their storage
system is now not very general purpose
this is a storage system that
understands what to do with my sequel
log entries right it's not just you know
EBS was a very general purpose just
emulated to disk you read them right
block's doesn't understand anything
about anything except for blocks this is
a storage system that really understands
that it's sitting underneath the
database so that's one thing they've
done is ditched general-purpose storage
and switched to a very application
specific storage system
the other big thing I'll also go into in
more detail is that they don't require
that the rights be acknowledged by all
six replicas in order for the database
server to continue instead the database
server can continue as long as a quorum
and which turns out to be for as long as
any four of these servers responds so if
one of these availability zones is
offline or maybe the network connection
to it is slow or maybe even just these
servers just happen to be slow doing
something else at the moment we're
trying to write the database server can
basically ignore the two slowest or the
two most dead of the server's when it's
doing it right so it only requires
acknowledgments from any four out of six
and then it can continue and so this
quorum scheme is the other big trick
they use to help them have more replicas
in more availability zones and yet not
pay a huge performance penalty because
they never have to wait for all of them
just the four fastest of the six
replicas so the rest of the lecture is
gonna be explaining first quorums and
then log entries and then this idea of
just sending log entries basically table
one summarizes the result if you look at
table one by switching from this
architecture in which they send the big
data pages to four places to this Aurora
schema sending just the log entries to
six replicas they get a amazing 35 times
performance increase over some other
system you know this system over here
but by playing these two tricks and
paper is not very good about explaining
how much of the performance is due to
quorums and how much is due to just
sending log entries but anyway you slice
it 35
times improvement performance is very
respectable and of course extremely
valuable to their customers and to them
and it's like transformative I am sure
for many of Amazon's customers all right
okay so the first thing I want to talk
about in in detail is their quorum
arrangement what they actually mean by
quorums so first of all the quorums is
all about the arrangement of
fault-tolerant of this fault-tolerant
storage so it's worth thinking a little
bit about what their fault tolerance
goals were so this is like fault
tolerance goals they wanted to be able
to do rights even if one reads and
writes even if one availability zone was
completely dead so they're gonna write
you know even with they wanted to be
able to read even if there was one dead
availability zone plus one other dead
server and the reason for this is that
an availability zone might be offline
for quite a while because maybe it's you
know was suffered from a flood or
something and while it's down for a
couple of days or a week or something
well people prepare the damage from the
flood we're now reliant on just you know
the servers and the other two
availability zones if one of them should
go down we still we don't want it to be
a disaster so they're going to be able
to write with one even with one dead
availability zone they furthermore they
wanted to be able to read with one dead
availability zone plus one other dead
server so they wanted to be able to
still read you know and get the correct
data even if there was one dead
availability zone plus one other server
and the live availability zones were
dead so you know they we have to sort of
take take it for granted that they know
what their they know their own business
and that this is really
you know kind of a sweet spot for how
fault-tolerant you want to be um and in
addition I already mentioned they want
to be able to taller to sur ride out
temporarily slow replicas I think from a
lot of sources it's clear that the if
you read and write EBS for example you
don't get consistently high performance
all the time sometimes there's little
glitches because maybe some part of the
network is overloaded or something is
doing a software upgrade or whatever and
it's temporarily slow so they want to be
able to just keep going despite
transient transiently slow or maybe
briefly unavailable storage servers and
a final requirement is that if something
if a storage server should fail it's a
bit of a race against time before the
next storage server fails sort of always
the case and it's not the statistics are
not as favorable as you might hope
because typically you buy basically
because server failure is often not
independent like the fact that one
server is down often means that there's
a much increased probability that
another one of your servers will soon go
down because it's identical Hardware may
be bought from the same company came off
the same production line one after
another and so a flaw and one of them is
extremely likely to be reflected in a
flaw and another one so people always
nervous off there's one failure boy
there could be a second failure very
soon and in a system like this well it
turns out in these quorum systems you
know you can only recover it's a little
bit like raft you can recover as long as
not too many of the replicas fail so
they really needed to have fast we
replicate them that is of one server
seems permanently dead we'd like to be
able to generate a new replica as fast
as possible from the remaining replicas
I mean a fast food replication
these are the main fault tolerance goals
the peeper lays out and by the way this
discussion is only about the storage
servers and you know what their failure
character is too excited you know the
failures how to recover and it's a
completely separate topic what to do if
the database server fails and Aurora has
a totally different set of machinery for
noticing a database servers fail
creating a new instance running in a new
database server on the new instance
which is intense it's not what I'm
talking about right now we'll talk about
it a little bit later on right now it's
just gonna build a storage system that's
a lot that's where the storage system is
fault tolerant okay so they use this
idea called quorums and for a little
while now I'm going to describe the sort
of classic quorum idea which is dates
back to the late 70s so this is quorum
replicate quorum replication I'm gonna
describe to you this or abstract quorum
idea they use a variant of what I'm
gonna explain and the idea of behind
quorum quorum systems is to be able to
build storage systems that provide fault
tolerance storage using replications and
guarantee that even if some of the
replicas fail your that reads will still
see the most recent writes and typically
quorum systems are sort of simple
readwrite systems put get systems and
they don't typically directly support
more complex operations just you can
read you could have objects you can read
an object or you can overwrite an entire
object and so the idea is you have n
replicas if you want to write or you
have to get you have to in order to
write you have to make sure your write
is acknowledged by W where W is less
than n of the replicas so W
right you have to send each right to
these W are the replicas and if you want
to do a read you have to get input read
information from at least our replicas
and so a typical setup that's so well
first of all the key thing here is that
W and our have to be set relative to end
so that any quorum of W servers that you
manage to send a right to must
necessarily overlap with any quorum of
our servers that any future reader might
read from and so what that means is that
our plus W has to be greater than n so
that any W servers must overlap in at
least one server with any our servers
and so you might have three we can
imagine there's three servers s1 s2 s3
each of them holds I say we just have
one object that we're updating we send
out a write maybe we want to set the
value of our object to 23 well in order
to do a write we need to get our new
value on to at least W of the of the
replicas let's say for this system that
R and W are both equals 2 and n is equal
to 3 that's the setup to do a write we
need to get our new value onto a quorum
onto a beast to the server so maybe we
get our right onto these two so they
both now know that the value of the of
our data object is 23 if somebody comes
along and reads or read it also requires
that the reader check with at least a
read quorum of the servers so that's
also 2 in this set up so you know that
quorum could include a server that
didn't see the right but it has to
include at least one other in order to
get to so that means the any future read
must for example consult both this
server that didn't see the write plus at
least one that did
that is a requirement of right form must
overlap in at least one server so any
read must consult a server that saw any
previous right now what's cool about
this well actually there's still one
critical missing piece here the reader
is gonna get back our results possibly
are different results because and the
question is how does a reader know which
of the our results it got back from the
our servers in its forum which one
actually uses the correct value
something that doesn't work is voting
like just voting by popularity of the
different values it gets back it turns
out not to work because we're only
guaranteed that our reader overlaps of
the writer in at most one server so that
could mean that the correct value is
only represented by one of the servers
that the reader consulted and you know
in a system with say six replicas you
know you might have Reaper might be four
you might get back for answers and only
one of them is the answer that is the
correct answer from the server in which
you overlap with the previous right so
you can't use voting and instead these
quorum systems need version numbers so
every right every time you do a right
you need to accompany your new value
with you know an increasing version
number and then the reader it gets back
a bunch of different values from the
read quorum and it can just use them
only the highest version number I'm said
that means that this 21 here
you know maybe s2 had a old value of 20
each of these needs to be tagged with a
version number so maybe this is version
number three this was also version
number three because it came from the
same original right and we're imagining
that this server that didn't see the
right is gonna have version number two
then the reader gets back these two
values these two version numbers fix the
version were the highest the value with
the highest version number and in Aurora
this was essentially about well never
mind about Aurora for a moment
okay furthermore if you can't talk to if
you can't actually contact a quorum or a
read or write you really just have to
keep trying those are the rules so keep
trying until the server's are brought
back up or connected again so the reason
why this is preferable to something like
chain replication is that it can easily
ride out temporary dead or disconnected
or slow servers so in fact the way it
would work is that if you want to read
or write if you want to write you would
saying your newly written about you
would send the newly written value plus
its version number to all of the servers
to all n of the servers but only wait
for W of them to respond and similarly
if you want to read you would in a
quorum system you would send the read to
all the servers and only wait for a
quorum for R of the servers to respond
and that and because you only have to
wait for are out of n of them that means
that you can continue after the fastest
are have responded or the fastest W and
you don't have to wait for a slow server
or a server that's dead and there's not
any you know the machinery for ignoring
slow or dead servers is completely
implicit there's nothing here or about
oh we have to sort of make decisions
about which servers are up or down or
like the leaders or anything it just
kind of automatically proceeds as long
as the quorum is available so we get
very smooth handling of dead or slow
servers in addition there's not much
leeway for it here well actually you
even in this simple case you can adjust
the R and W to make either reads to
favor either reads or writes so here we
could actually say that well the right
forum is three every write has to go to
all three servers and in that case the
read quorum can be want so you could if
you wanted to favored reads with this
setup you could have read equals one
write equals three memories are much
faster they only have to wait for one
server but then return the writes are
slow if you wanted to favor right
you could say that Oh any reader has to
be from all of them but a writer only
has to write one so I mean the only one
server might have the latest value but
readers have to consult all three but
they're guaranteed that their three will
overlap with this of course these
particular values makes writes not fault
tolerant and here reads not fault
tolerant because all the server's have
to be up so you probably wouldn't want
to do this in real life you might have
you would have as Knowle Rohrer does a
larger number of servers and sort of
intermediate numbers of vinum right
corns Aurora in order to achieve its
goals here of being able to write with
one debt availability zone and read with
one dead availability zone plus one
other server it uses a quorum system
with N equals 6 w equals 4 and R equals
3 so the W equals 4 means that it can do
a write with one dead availability zone
if this availability zone can't be
contacted well these other four servers
are enough to complete right the reform
of 3 so 4 plus week so 7 so they
definitely guaranteed overlap a read
quorum of 3 means that even if one
availability is zone is dead plus one
more server the three remaining servers
are enough to serve a read now in this
case we're three servers are now down
the system can do reads and as you know
can reconstruct the confine the current
state of the database but it can't do
writes without further work so if they
were in a situation where there was
three dead servers there they have
enough of a quorum to be able to read
the data and reconstruct more cop more
replicas but until they've created more
replicas to basically replace these dead
ones they can't serve as rights
and also the quorum system as I
explained before allows them to ride out
these transient slow replicas all right
as it happens as explained before what
the rights in Aurora aren't really over
writing objects as in a sort of classic
quorum system what Aurora in fact its
rights never overwrite anything its
rights just append log entries to the
current law
so the way it's using quorums is
basically to say well when the database
sends out our new log record because
it's executing some transaction it needs
to make sure that that log record is
present on at least four of the store of
its storage servers before it's allowed
to proceed with the transaction are
committed so that's really the meaning
of its other Wars right porins is that
each new log record has to be appended
to the storage and at least for the
replicas before the write can be
considered to to have completed and when
a when Aurora gets to the end of a
transaction before it can reply to the
client until the client tell the client
a hi you know your transaction is
committed and finished and durable
Aurora has to wait for acknowledgments
from a write quorum for each of the log
records that made up that transaction
and in fact because because if there
were a crash in a recovery you're not
allowed to recover one transaction if
preceding transactions don't aren't also
recovered in practice Aurora has before
Aurora can acknowledge a transaction it
has to wait for a write quorum of
storage servers to respond for all
previously committed transaction and the
transaction of interest and then can
respond to the client
okay so these these storage servers are
getting incoming log records
that's what rights look like to them and
so what do they actually do you know
they're not getting new data pages from
the database server they're just getting
log records that just describe changes
to the data pages so internally one of
these one of these storage servers it
has internally it has copies of all that
data of all the data pages at some point
in the database data pages evolution so
it has maybe in its cache on its disk a
whole bunch of these pages you know page
1 page 2 so forth when a new write comes
in the storage server would win a new
log rec over in a new write arrives
carrying with it just a log record what
has to happen some day but not right
away is that the changes in that log
record the new value here has to be
applied to the relevant page but we
don't at the source of it doesn't have
to do that until someone asks just until
the database server or the recovery
software asks to see that page so
immediately what happens to a new log
record is that the log records are just
appended to lists of log records that
effect each page so for every page that
the storage server stores if it's been
recently modified by a log record by a
transaction what the storage server will
actually store is an old version of the
page plus the string of the sequence of
log records that have come in from trend
from the database server since that page
was last brought up to date so if
nothing else happens the storage server
just stores these old pages plus lists
of log records if the database server
later you know fix the page from its
cache and then needs to read the page
again for a future transaction it'll
send a read request out to one of the
storage servers and say look you know I
need a copy I need an updated copy a
page one
and at that point the storage server
will apply these log records to the page
you know do do these writes of new data
that are implied that are described in
the log records and then send that
updated page back to the database server
and presumably maybe then like a racist
list and just store the newly updated
page although it's not quite that simple
all right so the storage servers just
store these strings of log records plus
old log page versions now the database
server as I mentioned sometimes needs to
read pages so by the way one thing to
observe is that the database server is
writing log records but it's reading
data pages so there's also different my
corns poram system in the sense that the
sort of things that are being read and
written are quite different in addition
it turns out that in ordinary operation
the database server knows doesn't have
to send quorum reads because the
database server tracks for each one of
the storage servers how far how much of
the prefix of the log that storage
server is actually received so the
database server is keeping track of
these six numbers so so first of all log
entries are numbered just one two three
four five the database server sends that
new log entries to all the storage
servers the storage servers that receive
them respond saying oh yeah I got log
entries 79 and furthermore you know I
have every log entry before 79 also the
database server keeps track of these
numbers how far each server has gotten
or what the highest sort of contiguous
log entry number is that each of the
servers has gotten so that way when the
database server needs to do a read it
just picks a storage server that's up to
date and sends the read request for the
page it wants just to that storage
server so the the database server does
have to do quorum writes but it
basically
doesn't ordinarily have to do quorum
reads and knows which of these storage
servers are up to date and just reads
from one of them so the reason I keep ur
than they would be in a that just reads
one copy of the page and doesn't have to
go through the expense of a quorum read
now it does sometimes use quorum reads
it turns out that during crash recovery
you know if the crash during crash
recovery of the database server and so
this is different from a crash recovery
of the storage service if the database
server itself sir crash in me because
the it's running in an ec2 instance on
some piece of hardware some real piece
of hardware may be that piece of
hardware suffers a failure the database
server crashes there's some monitoring
infrastructure at Amazon that says oh
wait a minute you know the database the
Aurora database server over running for
a customer or whatever just crashed and
Amazon will automatically fire up a new
ec2 instance start up the database
software and that ec2 instance and sort
of tell it look your data is sitting on
this particular volume this set of
storage systems please clean up any
partially executed transactions that are
evident in the logs stored in these
storage servers and continue so we have
to and that's the point at which Aurora
uses quorum logic for weeds because this
database server when the old when the
previous database server crashed it was
almost certainly partway through
executing some set of transactions so
the state of play at the time of the
crash was well it's completed some
transactions and committed them and
their log entries are on a quorum plus
it's in the middle of executing some
other set of transactions which also may
have log entries on on a quorum but
because a database server crashed midway
through those transactions they can
never be completed and for those
transactions that haven't completed in
addition there may be you know we may
have a situation in which you know maybe
log entry this server has log on three
hundred
and the Surrey has logon 302 and there's
a hundred and four somewhere but no you
know for I as yet uncommitted
transaction before the crash made me
know server got a copy of log entry 103
so after a crash and remember the new
database service recovering it does
quorum reads to basically find the point
in the log the highest log number for
which every preceding log entry exists
somewhere in the storage service so
basically it finds the first missing the
number of the first missing log entry
which is 103 and says well and so we're
missing a log entry we can't do anything
with a log after this point because
we're like missing an update so the
database server does these quorum reads
it finds a hundred and three is the
first entry that's MIT that's I can't
you know I look at my quorum the
server's I can reach and 103 is not
there and the database server will send
out a message to all the server saying
look please just discard every log entry
from 103 onwards and those mussels
necessarily not include log entries from
committed transactions because we know a
transaction can't commit until all of
its entries are on a right corner so we
would be guaranteed to see them so we're
only discarding log entries from
uncommitted transactions of course so
we're sort of cutting off the log here
at login 302 these log entries that
we're preserving now may actually
include log entries from uncommitted
transactions from transactions that were
interrupted by the crash and the
database server actually has to detect
those which you can by seeing a hope you
know a certain transaction there's it
has update entries in the log but no
commit record the database server will
find the full set of those uncompleted
transactions and basically issue undo
operations I sort of knew log entries
that undo all of the changes that that
that those uncommitted transactions made
and you know that's the point at which
Aurora needs this these old values in
the log entries so that a
server that's doing recovery after a
crash can sort of back out of partially
completed transactions all right one
another thing I'd like to talk about is
how Aurora deals with big databases so
so far I've explained the storage setup
as if the database just has these six
replicas of its storage and if that was
all there was to it basically a database
couldn't be you know each of these just
a computer with a disk or two or
something attached to it if this were
the way the full situation then we
couldn't have a database that was bigger
than the amount of storage that you
could put on a single machine there's
the fact that we have six machines
doesn't give us six times as much usable
storage because each one I'm storing a
replica of the same old data again and
again and you know so I want to use
solid-state drives or something we can
put you know terabytes of storage on a
single machine but we can't put you know
hundreds of terabytes on a single
machine so in order to support customers
who need like more than ten terabytes
who need to have vast databases Amazon
is happy Amazon will split up the
databases data onto multiple sets of six
replicas so and the kind of unit of
sharding the unit of splitting up the
data I think is 10 gigabytes so a
database that needs 20 gigabytes of data
will use two protection groups these
these PG things to its data you know sit
on half of it will sit on the six
servers of protection Group one and then
they'll be another six servers you know
possibly a different set of six storage
servers because Amazon's running and
like a huge fleet of these storage
servers that are jointly used by all of
its Aurora customers the second ten
gigabytes of the databases 20 gigabytes
of data
we'll be replicated on another set of
you know typically different I'll you
know there could be overlap between
these but typically just a different set
of six server so now we get 20 gigabytes
a day done and we have more of these as
a database goes bigger one interesting
piece of fallout from this is that while
it's clear that you can take the data
pages and split them up over multiple
independent protection groups maybe you
know odd numbered data pages from your
b-tree go on PG one and even number
pages go on PG - it's good you can shard
split up the data pages it's not
immediately obvious what to do with a
log all right how do you split up the
log if you have two of these two
protection groups or more in a mantra
tection group and the answer that amazon
does is that that that Aurora uses is
that the database server when it's
sending out a log record it looks at the
data that the log record modifies and
figures out which protection groups
store that data and it sends each log
record just to the protection groups
that store data that's mentioned that's
modified in the log entry and so that
means that each of these protection
groups store some fraction of the data
pages plus all the log records that
apply to those data pages see these
protection groups stores a subset of a
log that's relevant to its pages so a
final maybe I erase the photons
requirements but a final requirement is
that if a if ass one of these storage
servers crashes we want to be able to
replace it as soon as possible right
because you know if we wait too long
then we risk maybe three of them are
four of them crashing and a four of them
crash then we actually can't recover
because then we don't have a reform
anymore so we need to regain replication
as soon as possible if you think about
any one storage server sure this this do
which server is storing 10 gigabytes for
you know my databases protection group
but in fact the physical thing you know
the physical setup of any one of these
servers is that it has a you know maybe
a one or two or something
terabyte disk on it that's storing 10
gigabyte segments of a hundred or more
different Aurora instances so what's
what's on this physical machine is you
know 10 terabyte era byte or 10
terabytes or whatever of data in total
so when there's a when one of these
storage servers crashes it's taking with
it not just the 10 gigabytes from my
database but also 10 gigabytes from a
hundred other people's databases as well
and what has to be replicated is not
just my 10 gigabytes but the entire
terabyte or whatever or more that's
stored on this servers solid-state drive
and if you think through the numbers you
know maybe we have 10 gigabit per second
network interfaces if we need to move 10
terabytes across a 10 gigabyte per
second network interface from one
machine to another it's gonna take I
don't know a thousand seconds ten
thousand seconds maybe ten thousand
seconds and that's way too long right we
don't want to have to sit there and wait
you know it we don't want to have a
strategy in which the way we weak we can
reconstruct this is to find is to have
another machine that was replicating
everything on it and had that machine
send 10 terabytes to a replacement
machine we're gonna be able to
reconstruct the data far faster than
that and so the actual setup they use is
that if I have a particular storage
server
it stores many many segments you know
replicas of many 10 gigabyte protection
groups so maybe this protection group
maybe this segment that it's storing
data for the other envy for this one the
other replicas are you know these five
other machines all right so these are
all storing
segments of protection group a and so
you know there's a whole bunch of other
ones that we're also storing so I mean
we may be this particular machine also
stores a replica for protecting group B
but the other copies of the data for B
are going to be put on a disjoint set of
servers right so now there's five
servers that have the other copies of B
and so on for all of the segments that
this server that are sitting on this
storage servers hard drive for you know
many many different Aurora instances so
that means that this machine goes down
the replacement strategy is that we pick
if we're say we're storing a hundred of
these segments on it we pick a hundred
different storage servers each of which
is gonna pick up one new segment that is
each of which is going to now be
participating in one more protection
group so one one we miss like one server
to be replicate on for each of these ten
gigabytes segments and now we have you
know maybe 100 sort of different segment
servers and you know I probably storing
other stuff but they have a little bit
of free disk space and then for each of
these we pick one machine one of the
replicas that we're going to copy the
data from one of the remaining replicas
so maybe for a we're going to copy from
there for B from here you know if we
have five other copies with C we pick a
different server for C and so we have we
copy a from this server to that server
and B like this and C like this and so
now we have a hundred different 10
gigabyte copies going on in parallel
across the network and assuming you know
we have enough servers that these can
all be disjoint and we have plenty of
bandwidth in switching network that
connects them now we can copy our
terabyte or 10 terabytes or whatever of
data and total in parallel with a
hundredfold parallelism and the whole
thing will take you know 10 seconds or
something instead of taking a thousand
seconds if there were just two machines
involved anyway so this is
this is the strategies they use and it
means that they can recover you know for
machine dies they can recover in
parallel from one machine's death
extremely quickly if lots of machines
diets doesn't work as well but they can
recover from single they can be
replicate from single machine crashes
extremely quickly alright so a final
thing that the paper mentions if you
look at figure three you'll see that not
only do they have this main database but
they also have replica databases so for
many of their customers many of their
customers see far more read-only queries
than they see readwrite queries that is
if you think about a web server if you
just view a web page on some website
then chances are the web server you
connected to has to read lots and lots
and stuff in order to generate all the
things that are shown on the page to you
maybe hundreds of different items have
to be read out of the database or so out
of some database but the number of
writes for a typical web page view is
usually much much smaller maybe some
statistics have to be updated or a
little bit of history for you or
something so you might have a hundred to
one ratio of reads to writes that is you
may typically have a large large large
number of straight read only database
queries now with this set up the writes
can only go through the one database
server because we really can only
support one writer for this storage
strategy and I think you know one place
where the rubber really hits the road
there is that the log entries have to be
numbered sequentially and that's easy to
do if all the writes go through a single
server and extremely difficult if we
have lots of different servers all sort
of writing in an uncoordinated way to
the same database so the writes really
have to be go through one database but
we could set up and indeed Amazon does
set up a situation where we have read
only database replicas that can read
from these storage servers and so the
full glory of figure three is that in
addition to the main database server
that handles the write requests there's
also a set of read-only
databases and they say they can support
up to 15 so you can actually get a lot
of you know if your senior we'd have you
workload a lot of it can be you know
most of it can be sort of hived off to a
whole bunch of these read-only databases
and when a client sends a read request
to read only database what happens is
the read only database figures out you
know what data pages it needs to serve
that request and sends reads into the
directly into the storage system without
bothering the main readwrite database so
the the read-only replica database
ascend page requests read requests
directly the storage servers and then
they'll be no cache those pages so that
they can you know respond to future read
requests right out of their cache of
course they need to be able to update
those caches and for that reason Aurora
also the main database sends a copy of
its log to each of the read-only
databases and that's the horizontal
lines you see between the blue boxes and
figure three that the main database
sends all the log entries do these mean
only databases which they use to update
their cached copies to reflect recent
transactions in the database and it
means it does mean that the read only
database is lag a little bit behind the
main database but it turns out for a lot
of read-only workloads that's okay if
you look at a web page and it's you know
20 milliseconds out of date that's
usually not a big problem there are some
complexities from this like one problem
is that we don't want these relay
databases to see data from uncommitted
transactions yet and so in this stream
of log entries the database may need to
be sort of denotes which transactions
have committed and they're read-only
databases are careful not to apply
uncommon
uncommitted transactions to their caches
they wait till the transactions commit
the other complexity that these
read-only replicas impose is that
the the the these structures he of these
andhe structures are quite complex this
might be a b-tree it might need to be
rebalanced periodically for example I'm
the rebalancing is quite a complex
operation in which a lot of the tree has
to be modified in atomically and so the
tree is incorrect while it's being be
balanced and you only allowed to look at
it after the rebalancing is done if
these read-only replicas directly read
the pages out of the database there's a
risk they might see the be tree that the
database that's being stored here in
these data pages they may see the bee
tree in the middle of a rebalancing or
some other operation and the data is
just totally illegal and they might
crash or just malfunction and when the
paper talks about mini transactions and
the vdl verses vcl distinction what it's
talking about is the machinery by which
the database server can tell the storage
servers look this complex sequence of
log entries must only be revealed all or
nothing' atomically to any read-only
transactions that's what the mini
transactions and VDL are about and
basically the read when a read only
database asks to see data a data page
from a storage server the storage server
is careful to either show it data from
just before one of these sequence many
transaction sequences of log entries or
just after but not in the middle all
right so that's the all the technical
stuff I have to talk about just to kind
of summarize what's interesting about
the paper and what can be learned from
the paper one thing to learn which is
just good in general not specific to
this paper but everybody in systems
should know is the basics of how
transaction processing databases work
and the sort of impact that the
interaction between transaction
processing databases and the storage
systems because this comes up a lot it's
like a pervasive you know the
performance and crash recoverability
complexity of running a real database
just comes up over and over again in
systems design another thing to learn
this paper is this idea of quorums and
overlap the technique of overlapping
read/write quorums in order to always be
able to see the latest data but also get
fault tolerance and of course this comes
up in raft also raft has a strong kind
of quorum flavor to it
another interesting thought from this
paper is that the database and the
storage system are basically Co designed
as kind of an integrated there's
integration across the database layer
and the storage layer or nearly
redesigned to try to design systems so
they have you know good separation
between consumers of services and the
sort of infrastructure services like
typically storage is very
general-purpose not aimed at a
particular application just you know
because that's a pleasant design and it
also means that lots of different uses
can be made of the same infrastructure
but here the performance issues were so
extreme you know they would have to get
a 35 times performance improvement by
sort of blurring this boundary this was
a situation in which general-purpose
storage was actually really not
advantageous and they got a big win by
abandoning that idea and a final set of
things to get out of the papers all the
interesting sometimes kind of implicit
information about what was valuable to
these Amazon engineers who you know
really know what they're doing about
what concerns they had about cloud
infrastructure like the amount of worry
that they put into the possibility of an
entire availability zone might fail it's
an important tidbit the fact that
transient slowness of individual storage
servers was important is another thing
that actually also comes up a lot and
finally the implication that the network
is the main bottleneck because after all
they were it went to extreme lengths to
send less data over the network
but in return the storage servers have
to do more work and they put it they're
willing to you know 6 copies the data
and have 6 CPUs all replicating the
execution of applying these redo log
entries apparently CPU is relatively
cheap for them whereas the network
capacity was extremely important
all right that's all I have to say and
see you next week